hi everybody oh my god the pressure
share your intentions go ahead and share
on Sharon
I'm Tanya Holland I'm the chef-owner
brown sugar kitchen thank you thank you
restaurant in Oakland California and I'm
gonna let you in on a secret
I am a huge procrastinator and what I
love about the restaurant business is
that I can't procrastinate because I
can't be like oh you know I think I'll
put that chick in the fridge in a couple
hours you know I'm gonna go to that
guy's table and if you know a few
minutes so the restaurant business
forces me to like just do stuff so you
know I I was asked to speak to you guys
months ago but when do you think I
started working on my speech and I know
that some of you know me and my story as
a chef and entrepreneur and you know
I've been speaking a lot out loudly
lately about you know being a black
woman this business being a woman in
this business entrepreneur I don't want
to talk about that anymore I'm actually
really tired of talking about I mean
it's very important and it's something I
want to continue to do but I want to do
something different with you guys
tonight I want to talk to you about
dancing and how much I love to dance
and how important it is to me and how I
think everybody should learn to dance
and it's such an important life skill
because I mean I do it every day in my
work when I cook I dance the soundtrack
at brownshirt kitchen is so important to
me I'm always listening for music levels
there's a lot of songs that you know are
my particular favorites but also
reminiscent of the cuisine soul food so
music but there's also some of my 80s
stuff in the mix if you listen closely
and you know cooking its and working in
environment it's all about dancing
you know pivoting pausing marking your
next move and just having a rhythm and a
balance and being aware of your
surroundings I talked about this to my
staff all the time they don't seem to
quite get it but I think it's just
you know too many of those like rage
parties yeah it's like it's different I
didn't grow up like I danced differently
anyways so I also like you know I
yeah I'd feel more comfortable
improvising than you know talking off
script I have my cards over there like a
little security blanket just in case I
need them but I want to tell you guys
that I really I wanted to be a dancer I
asked my dad when I was a young girl if
I could be a dancer he's like oh no I'll
never put a dancer through school I was
like ouch really okay and you know this
whole conversation is about kind of
holding your vision I mean this is you
know I consider myself a visionary and
I've had this vision for my life for a
long time but you just you never know
where life is going to take you so you
you need to know how to pivot how to
dance and later on you know I start
going along and I asked him if I could
be President and I didn't mean you know
president itíd States and he's like well
you could be which was amazing you know
in the 70s he said yeah I could be to
his little black girl here's what I
wouldn't recommend it he said it costs a
lot of money and there's a lot of people
blowing smoke up your butt like verbatim
he said that it was like oh okay so I
don't know somehow I found out what
architect was and I said oh can I be an
architect that sounds exciting is like
man he goes I wouldn't you won't make
any money be an engineer so I applied to
engineering schools I you know good
daughter and I went to school for
engineering and I graduated with a
degree in Russian language and
literature
right and that's a longer story we don't
have enough time for that but little did
they know you know I was dancing all the
time so I graduate with this degree and
then this ability to dance what am I
going to do I'm going to work in the
restaurant business that's the only
place you can go I used to you know call
it the land of misfit toys because it is
it's sort of like that place it more so
was when I was coming up of where people
ended up where they didn't know what
they wanted to do or be in life now
people intentionally go into the
business because it's all romanticized
with the TV and celebrity chefs and like
I'm a celebrity chef even though earlier
today I was like unplugging the toilet
and mopping up pig's blood but it you
know celebrity so I start working in
restaurants and I just fell in love with
them and I became a Francophile when I
started studying French in ninth grade
and my birthday's best deal day
something I'm going to France France for
cooking school so I go there and I'm in
the Chateau and the burgundy and it's
wonderful it's great and then the school
split up in two semesters so I went to
Paris and my French wasn't good enough
just work in a French restaurant on the
further house so I worked at the Chicago
pizza pie Factory and in a black a-frame
dress with a name tag and guess what I
had to dance
I was part of my job description was to
dance to greased lightning twice a night
that's right and it was all
choreographed by the manager but I'm not
gonna do it right now but you know I
realized so but I got some of the best
tips because I know how to dance and you
know it's just not being rigid it's
about not being rigid and your steps and
you know your vision and your work and
what you want out of life and just kind
of going with it and you know that sort
of give-and-take of just the steps so I
you know I finished up my time there and
I ended up in New York working and
cooking dancing on bars you know Dan
always going to dance bar it's just
dancing dancing dancing and then I ended
up in Oakland and
I fell in love with it I was going to
open up a French Creole Bistro that was
what I wanted I love the intersection of
African and French cooking and I just
thought like this community would
embrace that and I did not get the real
estate that I was looking for I didn't
get the opportunity so I had to pivot I
had to you know be really flexible and
you know pause for a minute figure out
what am I gonna do and I found this
space in West Oakland and I thought okay
well I guess I got a you know change up
the concept make it really accessible
this community and brownshirt kitchen
was born a happy accident and yeah thank
you
thank you ten oh by the way just
celebrated ten years in business and
yeah I'm convinced that it's because you
know I have had this ability to just go
you know kind of in and out of
situations and you know dancing requires
you to also be comfortable in your own
skin because you know or you can dance
like nobody's watching it's like a
statement that people say you really
have to feel comfortable and I was gonna
do some dance moves for you guys but I
don't know we'll see if you get if
you're lucky you know I grew up the ark
was like you know R&B my first concert
was Jackson's
then I saw the off of all I'm really oh
by the way I'm like I'm 52 I'll be 53
this year so I might make I might make
some 80s pop culture references that you
don't understand but it's okay and you
know one of the reasons I want to be a
dancer cuz I was obsessed with Fame
growing up was just like you know now
it's called Glee but it was Fame and I
love this diverse population there was a
very diverse student body and Oakland's
very diverse and it's just what I've
been striving for my whole life and I've
been able to create that in my
restaurant but you know it was like
after the Jackson's I was an awesome
wall tour and it was like I wanna rock
with you
oh you guys missed out on like being the
rich
I know you guys listen to it now but
like when it first came out it was great
you know and I still play that the
restaurant and then you know I get to
the restaurant and I've opened my doors
and I'm looking around I created this
very diverse environment I did not
aspire to open a breakfast and lunch
place I mean I don't like getting up at
5:00 in the morning but I'm there and
but it was all that was available to me
at the time and you know I went in there
and I improvised and I you know just
kind of created something that I thought
you know maybe could be sustainable for
a while
and it has its lasted and I realized one
day you know I'm walking around the
space and I'm like I'm president of my
company and I'm the architect of my
environment and I listen to the music I
want to so I dance all day long so I
thank you I just want to encourage you
guys to dance and you know again it's
about being aware of your surroundings
pausing don't go rushing trying to
barrel through it like I know what I
want to get to because you don't know
what life is gonna serve you and
pivoting when you can and being most of
all being graceful and gracious and you
know as you go through this world
because you know we're living even
closer together these days and we've got
to just be more you know graceful with
each other and gracious and polite and
you